break up suck but they're not the end of
the world there are going to be plenty
of more fish in the sea
so don't trip over one small one
everything was gonna be okay you're
allowed to do well on the tests which
are also allowed to fail sometimes and
you just keep going to not be afraid to
be yourself because back in the day I
was very shy and I was very reserved I
didn't get to do a lot of things that I
wish that I got to do just because of my
shyness the problems you think you're
having are like not a big deal like most
of these problems are gonna work
themselves out with age in high school I
was always scared of doing the wrong
thing or getting in trouble but now I
know that it's not that deep so go do
something you're scared of you should
not be afraid as cheesy as it sounds to
chase a dream that anything is possible
you really should just like follow your
heart
move away explore the world do whatever
you want and don't feel like you're
stuck wherever you are in high school
used to get made fun of a lot for making
YouTube videos so back then I wish that
I knew to just not get discouraged by
that I wish I knew that you could take a
gap year between high school and college
your college is really expensive so
missing out on some parties and actually
doing good on your SATs is a good idea
also save your money you have some type
of income in high school at least save
five bucks in a bank account so you have
money to your name when you get into
college and then in adulthood also it's
just like a good practice to have under
your belt I'm gonna switch it up a
little bit there are some things I wish
I knew in high school that I still don't
know like how to change a tire or how to
do taxes or just be an adult
[Music]